Now that you can load and
draw sprites and
animations, it's time to
start work on Gigagal.
In this level, we'll plan out
the structure of the game,
build out a project skeleton, and
set up our asset loading system.
Then we'll focus in on
creating Gigagal herself.
To keep track of the state of Gigagal,
and to know what sprite or
animation to draw, we need to keep
track of five things: Her position and
velocity, what direction she's facing,
whether or
not she's walking and what state
of jumping or falling she's in.
Giga gal is a complex class, for sure.
But at the end of this level,
we'll have a fun character to play with.
Let's get started.